non
mais là il veut qu'on soit s'écraser
mais attention il veut qu'on sera
s'écraser il est pour les fous complet
tu fais n'importe quoi
les gars les gars on entend des barbelés
je suis comme lui des barbelés j'aime
bien c'est sympa
[Musique]
je vous explique ce qui se passe
lancement du neuf nikon one parenthèse
de 1 qui est lancée aujourd'hui l'un
derrière ce que vous avez derrière c est
là que pour aller à l'événement de quel
événement qui va se lancer alors je vous
ai déjà fait une vidéo d'un boxing pour
vous présenter il y aurait une vidéo
test qui arrivera plus tard mais l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire ok comment
ça se passe quand une nouvelle marque
y'a même pas deux ans lance un
smartphone lors son premier smartphone
un peu différenciant intéressant comment
ça se passe donc l'idée c'est de venir
regarder les cuisses c'est plus du blog
on va regarder un peu ce qui se passe
quand je sertic hull est ce qu'on peut
parler avec les équipes si oui qu'est-ce
qu'on m'a alors dit qu'est ce qu'ils
vont nous le dire prendre un peu le coup
prend la température poissy devoir de
l'intérieur à quoi ressemble nothing qui
sont les gens et comment ça s'articule
tout un programme
pendant ce temps là la presse française
concentré fait son oeuvre vous êtes went
eu ce besoin de juger titouan frandroid
des ppp je suis vieux
je me suis assis en tailleur espérant
que quelqu'un melli treuil jusqu'à
l'endroit car sinon c'est contre ils ont
commandé une grue se content d'être là
c'est qu'on a vu des commerces s'appelle
pp on a même vu péter chilton on a vu
plein de choses de péta ici je pense que
c'est ta ville pp tu es né ici et
maintenant je sais c'est donc c'est une
vie de dépressif
ils doivent leur nom
[Musique]
parce que là on sait où on est
on vous explique comment ça se passe les
gens arrivent par l'entrée là bas il
s'arrête au stand bauchi enfin c'est
très bon ensuite il file par là bas voir
une petite coupe de champagne tu as bu
une coupe de champagne pour agression
non non c'est beaucoup trop tôt
absolument monsieur et puis vous avez un
écran géant qui est caché là bas
derrière on peut cela qu'on fait sinon
ça se passe là où voilà grosso modo cela
programme
[Musique]
pour faire un petit tour du propriétaire
parce qu'en fait là on va lieu la
conférence séchée muffins
les équipes qui sont là une partie lésée
qui fait le lieu où il bosse alors
priori aura un autre local je sais donc
pas très drôle mais ici on est chez nous
on n'est pas ailleurs on n'est pas dans
un vieux loup et pour l'événement c'est
plutôt bien parce que hamid de prendre
un peu de goût pour la température et
plantations les influences
cette espèce d'objet musicaux et
on va redescendre
là on est à l'état comme ça on commence
directement ici vous voyez il ya les
copains la team française qui est là
alors bon très très rapidement je vous
montre on voit ça c'est vachement ce que
ses côtés start-up londonienne avec je
sais pas si c'est une table c'est parce
que c'est réellement mais bon on est pas
mal là et puis on va prendre de la
hauteur voilà l'écran au fond là-bas des
petits bureaux pour venir bosser il y en
a un peu tous les côtés on prend les
escaliers on va le voir en bas ce qui se
passe juste en bas il fait beaucoup plus
chaud ici qu'est ce qui est écrit ci
l'en au jeu pas si vous arrivez à
nothing has il va mieux je vois mieux
travers la caméra que de mes propres
yeux alors pourquoi ce travers ça et
c'est ici on veut avoir lieu une partie
de la conf c'est beaucoup plus dégagée
il ya beaucoup moins de monde alors on
comprend parce qu'en fait il fait très
chaud ici ils ont joué vraiment ils sont
très fort en marketing en fait nothing
on le retrouve regarder la voix le
smartphone dans une poche noir ça
ressort vachement bien le smartphone au
niveau de l'oeil pareil là c'est en fait
il joue vraiment sur le côté oeuvres
d'art de l'objet plus que sur le côté
plus retek fonctionnalités
[Musique]
la cuisse ça va ça va oui oui ça y est
on y est on va profiter du coucher un
des cofondateurs de nothing pourrait
donc on va commencer ouais ça fait un
petit peu plus d'un an et demi
maintenant et ça y est on est le jour j
aujourd'hui un peu plus de nos ennemis
vous lancer un smartphone c'est donc
quand même c'est non c'est non et non
j'arrivais frissonner y penser
belle aventure belle aventure ça a été
compliqué ouais tu ne teste pas c'est
pas évident qu'aujourd'hui ça y est on
annonce officiellement le fond noir
ouais c'est cool c'est cool beaucoup de
gens aujourd'hui djadji mille personnes
qui attendent pour se connecter en ligne
j'ai regardé poursuivre ouais c'est cool
ça fait plaisir et non on a hâte de voir
ce que j'en pense les produits hasardeux
le faire son effet c'est une belle
histoire un premier smartphone un coup
de retour positif puisqu'on a déjà
montré le design de nos jours c'est de
plus en plus dur de garder les fuites et
c'était en cash et ouais donc on a
préféré montrer le design est à peu près
un mois et ça y est aujourd'hui on va
savoir toutes les specs tout le prix
dans dix minutes s'annoncent immunité
chez vous ici là c'est chez nous donc
ici c'est le design europe oui ici
allons d'accord d'autres bureaux un
petit peu plus bas là où il ya toute
l'équipe marketing ventes opérations etc
et si en fait c'est toute la partie
design kit a visité à l'est alors si je
suis donc on a fait une petite vibe je
peux street food on a voulu vraiment
garder un atmosphère un petit peu
convivial comme malouda démouchy à
l'entrée du champagne c'est sa petite
glace pour se rafraîchir sa déjà très
chaud et yann faisait très chaud là
c'est le petit coin champagne mois
robert 6 pourra se rafraîchir en fait
venir un petit foutraque aussi pour
citer
ici c'est le rez-de-chaussée on a tout
aménagé exprès pour
pour l'événement
les équipes qui bosse ici votre équipe
est à plein de machines etc donc on a
tout aménagé spécialement pour
l'événement voilà quelques personnes
inconnues au bataillon
c'est sa tâche et la burqa il faut aller
à l'état allez vas-y mon frère et agent
lagardère encore un petit peu les
bureaux
commence à être de gamme cet homme au
royaume couleurs
toute la partie dizaine d le design du
fron c'est lui ok
déjà on a un autre écran pour pour le
sprinteur a commencé dans 10 minutes
maintenant et voilà on a gardé un petit
peu quand même le bureau il y avait les
équipes derrière un petit peu de travail
et encore oui mais voilà talent et
d'inspiration je vois derrière alors que
nos amis les uns
son pleurs de votre lutte c'est quoi ce
truc de santé c'est un petit peu il ya
un petit peu du tyne engineering
ouais parce que du coaching générique
font partie de l'équipe cofondatrice de
nothing et one way on a lancé il ya
maintenant et non ça finalement ça fait
un ange
avant de tuer plus de 1,2 million
d'exemplaires ok donc c'est cool ça a
bien marché tommy est un premier projet
pour pour montrer un petit peu leur
identité en termes de design etc et
aujourd'hui le froid c'est le bbc
à bosser depuis le tout début et lancy
ferrari et entre nous personne ne s'en
remettent à la pression et beaucoup de
fatigue du contrat
voilà tout ce qu'il devait faire a été
fait donc maintenant voilà y'a plus qu'à
à tous les amis
tous les personnes jusqu à ce qu elle
comme tous les opérateurs et c'est
qu'ils ont énormément soutenu laventure
nothing ses inventeurs plusieurs
personnes qui sont tous que ajoutées au
projet noter que ce soit encore un poil
à la participation des partenaires comme
google qualcomm externe qui voyaient en
nous vraiment une vraie opportunité de
ramener quelque chose de nouveau dans
l'industrie et c'est cool aujourd'hui
tout le monde est là la soie les médias
fabriqué avec ont en fait déjà beaucoup
de choses dedans précédent et c'est cool
d'avoir tout le monde réuni aujourd'hui
tout le monde a un peu contribué dans
l'histoire de la fing et c'était un
petit peu l'idée on voulait garder ça un
peu fort maritime c'est pour ça qu'on a
voulu faire le sera dans les bureaux se
sent un peu plus convivial et paf
irlandais sera donc tu peux qui non
traditionnels et compagnie on a voulu
garder ça fresnoy
moi donc le manchec merci acquis et bon
courage merci à eux
[Musique]
attendu que six mois
qu'est-ce qu'on la pensait de ce
lancement
très sympa bien différent ils
m'attendent excuses le monde mais bon
c'est comme un premier smartphone que
lance la signer le parcours pour lancer
un smartphone est quand même très très
long donc chapeau bas pour on a ciblé
puisqu'il faisait quand même plus parce
que le smartphone
classique en soie et en toute honnêteté
je suis patient forcément que le glyphe
face à différents si longtemps points 3
affaire à suivre on regarde on regarde
toi trop près là et vous les gars sont
géniales toute chose tant ils sont
évidemment mais à part ça dans la
moiteur londonienne enfin franchement
avis sur le lâcher à chaud très chaud
mieux de gamme pas mal après ce combat
car sans un truc comme ça pourquoi pas
si on va avoir un truc qui sort un peu
du lot ouais a montré à ses potes de
temps en temps apple ce problème de
l'effet waouh quoi qui montre le droit
qui fait une démonstration 3,56
cognitive et où il ya beaucoup de ça
après sur la durée il faudra voir
comment il se tient pour la photo
l'autonomie évidemment et voir si on
peut faire quelque chose sur long terme
surtout choqué c'était d'amis à licata
du parisien que ça vient et on a dit
wang c'est une femme ont quitté
le cra mal bien pensez quoi de ce
lancement tant plus tôt
et
j'exagère mais tous les jours qu'on a
l'occasion de voir la naissance d'une
marque quoi donc par la naissance vous
avez déjà des écouteurs mais là c'est
carrément ses vrais débuts en fait le
vrai débat on a un peu l'impression et
wife and one comme ça un peu trash
écoute je le trouve plutôt confortable
avec
un peu moins confortable quand il
commence à habiter la nuit avec les
retrouvailles en avait j'ai tenté
l'expérience je ne sais pas non plus tôt
coup plutôt cool j'aime bien le côté
sans pour en fait ils ont en effet un
truc est très sain ok assez directe et
je pense que ça peut convaincre son
public verra comment ça prend aussi je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'il a été non
c'est mon film donne aussi son parti
olala des bisous des bisous et baby
enfin like this way plateforme youtube
santa chaîne youtube
incroyable deux heures de live de
heurter un faux dit il avait mal
commencé un passionné qui reste le
réseau d'environ envoyé là dedans eh ben
on était avec un débit en rien du tout
donc les gens commencent à crier moi
j'étais jeune j'étais triste parce que
je ne pas offrir une définition de 320
postes andrew on va pouvoir mesurer le
défi gens à monter on a terminé en 1080p
points ou mais au bout d'une heure qu'on
y est on sait qu'entre ce lancement eh
beh j'ai trouvé ça bizarre bizarre
bizarre pour le prendre mal français qui
allait avoir une scène avec karl avec
acquise selon les ingénieurs il faudrait
faire un show on allait filmer c'est à
dire un truc ap mais non c'était une
vidéo et puis après avec karl qui
étaient ici avait acquis sur les
ingénieurs les gens ça fait bizarre
comme sensation de son pouvoir la même
chose chez eux on est très différents
ces commandes et nous à la fin de la
vidéo on avait 1 avec arles qui était la
sienne inception quand elle sort de
l'écran ils arrivent ici pour apporter
la gloire l'amour de talent parce qu'on
n'a pas un truc de ouf mais le produit
est intéressant parce que c'est un
nouveau challenger c'est intéressant
d'avoir un nouveau produit qui se pointe
d'une marque pas aussi sûr ans et pointé
à tromso après les tests monsieur gros
d'amour dira ce que ça vous enfin voit
donc son prénom je m'étais fait de
casser auquel coiffeuse brisé en deux
voilà ce qu'attend on compare un peu à
peu de noms je vais en parler un peu
mais visiblement c'est un petit d'un
très bon haut de gamme du moyenne gamme
il ya du monde en face à y croire je
pense que le coach n'est pas là le côté
jeu côté qui je peux faire marrer un
petit peu mais c'est pas sa personnalité
les disruptif mais il ya d'autres trucs
deux enfants intéressant quand même ok
on mesure déjà que là on a un produit on
n'a pas finalisé pour rendez compte
finir plus haut qu'ils ont annoncé un
smartphone il ya neuf mois il ya un an
les stands des industriels manche par
phone pour en école de partenaires
qu'ils ont derrière on arrive à faire ça
en neuf mois mais aucune marque faire ça
je veux dire ses mémoires qui ont pignon
sur rue pas une marque des buts c'est du
délire quand même engagé un canon à
bientôt et un camion derrière moi il
avait aussi parce que monsieur brawn en
tête des valeurs
renault ça grossit face tu sais quoi tu
as les premiers valeur à partir en
vacances bientôt oui c'est vrai tu te
fais des bisous je fais des bisous
tellement étrange d'un magasin amusement
c'est bien les gars d'avoir un magasin
qui s'appelle amusement annoncé l'isaf
et d'isabelle soit l amusement pas ses
magasins twitter
s'est amusé même parc c'était une fête
foraine nouvel amusement york hu après
donc cette blague de pépé
[Musique]
bon alors pour finir cette petite vidéo
ici dans ma petite fiole d'hôtel alors
le lancement hyper intéressant qu'est ce
qu'on va qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est qu'effectivement d'un os x une
boîte qui est écrit ya pas longtemps car
aussi est levé beaucoup d'argent il ya
google excellent google vint turquie est
d'enfin bref il ya google il ya plein de
monde dedans il ya beaucoup
d'investisseurs c'est une boîte qui a
réussi quand même à fédérer beaucoup
beaucoup de monde pour réussir en moins
de deux ans a créé à sortir asmar contre
cabinda gaudin go le smartphone on en
parle sur youtube bien évidemment donc
je vous invite à bien vous a brillé
parce qu'on n'en pas très très bientôt
on en a 10 ans déjà peut-être parler vos
mots sur cette vidéo il se peut qu'elles
sont un petit peu en décalé ce que je
voulais vous montrer ici c'était
vraiment un peu les coulisses comment ça
se passe comment ça se structure dans
une boîte comme ça qu'est ce qu'on
arrive à sentir ce qu'on arrive à
percevoir au niveau de ce premier
lancement tout ça cool parce que même si
on al impression qu effectivement gala
qui nota les films et même si on voit
effectivement mais quelle des
intervenants qui viennent et qu'il n'y a
pas des millions de personnes comme il
pourrait y avoir sur une keynote à 400
500 600 personnes la mine de rien ils
savent très bien travaillé ça faire le
buzz ils savent créer la hype autour de
leur smartphone et ils savent proposer
un truc qui est un peu différent du
reste du marché donc je trouve que
l'idée est là l'idée hyper malines et le
smartphone et tricool voilà donc on en
reparlera probablement temps on parlera
de ce smartphone lors du test on repart
anoci ultérieurement et puis voilà donc
je trouvais ça cool je voulais partager
ça avec vous donc je passe ça peut vous
intéresser dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire et puis
très rapidement parce que j'aime bien
faire ça je montrais rapidement la fiole
toujours un petit truc que j'aime
partager avec vous alors je veux montrer
très vite ici nous ont réservé une truc
de maboule avec un truc très années 70
regardez ça là la petite baignoire là
est juste folle elle est complètement
dingue dingue on a en plus la petite
douche qui est là regardez là comme on
est bien et puis ils ont fait ou un truc
qui est assez dingue ou même le plafond
est un peu dingo voilà donc ça me fait
marrer voilà je voulais vous montrer ça
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
à parler take prenez soin de vous nous
en bras de gros bisous ya bientôt ciao